here with chocolaty Valentine treats
that are easy to make and good for you
too can you believe it the wonderful
abbey sharp is with us today taste so
identified chocolates and you know
flowers and whatever make your own kind
of stuff and it looks pretty banana
they're late yeah what are you gonna
make first first so we're gonna do my
banana ice cream puffs
okay so we start with some sliced banana
and what I just do is take a little bit
of all natural almond butter uh-huh so I
put in a little piping bag and you can
just do a little dollop on each of these
guys alright and then we go in with
another slice of banana obviously this
is so so simple to put together her you
know kids you can do this with your
hubby could just make a kind of like a
family affair and actually make it
interactive and fun it shouldn't be
stressful right so then I get these
little popsicle sticks squish them in
and these are gonna go into a freezer to
completely freeze until they're solid so
good one or two hours and we've got some
frozen okay meanwhile we will melt our
chocolate so I like using really good
good quality chocolate so nice dark 70%
and we're gonna melt it on there what we
call a bad memory or a double boiler
mmm-hmm so I've got a little bit of
water in the bottom of the pot just
about an inch and then I add a little
bit of coconut oil
mm-hmm and the coconut oil just helps it
to thin out so that it coats the the
fruit nice and evenly lemon bumps okay
and then we just simmer this on a very
low heat because you don't want to
scorch except so high quality and I've
got some melted right here so what we're
gonna do take our frozen banana pops dip
them all the way a natural chocolate so
they're completely
oh yeah people like that and one of
those some of the things you have yeah
so this is how we can kind of make it
interactive and it's just as much about
the experience and the time you spend
together as it is about having tasty
treats hmm so I put in some bowls of fun
festive okay let's go through this this
is pistachios candied ginger toasted
coconut
cranberries those are my peppercorn pink
peppercorn Wow
with chocolate yeah yeah yeah
freeze-dried strawberries some fleur de
sel cuz I love the sweet salt I do too
what is this part of the same thing a
little bit bigger okay sis okay
don't you berries yes also some
pistachios if you want them crushed up
right almonds and then capala beans like
that little bit you know more Antares
okay so let's just definite them and you
can see these pieces should dry kind of
set almost instantaneously and we've got
them all set out there how nice are
these what do you think about that's so
easy would you say all the butter almond
butter bananas chocolate can't go wrong
okay now you're gonna make some buttons
buttons buttons who's got the button so
this is even easier maybe you've got
younger kids you want to keep it silly
simple for you maybe got a man who's not
so culinary inclined this is a good rest
you aren't yourself yeah I can do that
plea this is soon a circle so we're just
putting this on a baking sheet line with
something nonstick like a little
parchment wax paper and I've just put in
you could make big buttons little
buttons whatever size you want and it's
that same dark chocolate humbly also
melted some white chocolate if you want
to kind of do a little bit of a drizzle
on top and you don't even need to go
ahead and buy fancy piping bags I just
put this in a plastic resealable bag cut
the corner out there you go and there
you go you can put a little design you
can add whatever you want
so I'm gonna do freeze-dried
strawberries this one this is my
favorite combo guys little freeze-dried
strawberries and some pink peppercorn
sweet Wow
maybe some salt chocolate chocolate yes
honestly nothing but then are you just
what do you do next then you just pop
these in the fridge or freezer till they
set up and look at this you've got like
a cute little bit back little DIY
buttons you can make them
and then making chocolate strawberry
white okay so like we all one of those
ladies get flowers for Valentine's Day
and that's nice I appreciate the gesture
but they die and I have to take care of
them I don't want to take care of my
Valentine's Day gift I want to eat it
yeah right
and that's what your name is too much
work so that's it the best of both
worlds strawberries which let's be
honest screen Valentine's Day they do
they look like little hearts in
themselves so I just take these little
wooden skewers easy to find it you know
at your grocery store pop them in where
the leaves are here so I'm just gonna
insert them like that there's your
flower there I rose your rose there you
go there's that chocolate again dip that
chocolate all the way in you love it
when she dips the chocolate it's sexy
tissue I can hear those the United Front
mmm yeah yeah and you know if you're
doing this it's a date night thing it's
a really fun little activity to do with
your partner it keeps it keeps a flirty
keeps it interactive and you know you
get if you get some chocolate on your
fingers gets messy it's all part of the
fun right it's a little sexy so we're
gonna do the almonds for this one cuz I
love that and the nice thing is you can
put make a bouquet of them yeah you can
put it in a pretty little jar you can
take an Instagram photo show off to all
your friends no could I did give the
Marilyn done a show credit especially a
be sharp all three recipes are in
Maryland say thank you to Abby
some heroes saving lives every day